We have some great discussions happening on
the David Pakman show sub Reddit, which you
can find at David Pakman dot com slash Reddit.
Interestingly, because of what the next story
is, one user, Ethan A. says it's time David
does a deep dove into Q Anon. And Ethan writes.
At first I understood the sentiment of not
wanting to give these unfounded, insane beliefs
any attention. However, that can no longer
be the case. And Ethan argues that because
so many people are now believing and embracing
the Q and unstuff that it's time for me to
deal with it. Well, Donald Trump seems to
also have
embraced it. Yesterday during a press briefing.
And so we're going to talk about it today.
In fact, user Katie all the time asks, how
will the U.S. deal with the anti vaccine is
refusing the vaccine when it comes out saying
one of my fears, once a vaccine for the coronavirus
comes out, is that a significant minority
will refuse it. Soon, the anti maskers will
turn into the anti vaccines and refuse the
vaccine. If, let's say, 30 percent of the
U.S. population refuses to take the vaccine.
How will the U.S. respond? Well, I hate to
burst what is already a very bad bubble, Katie,
but 40 to 50 percent of Americans as of right
now say they will not take a corona virus
vaccine. So I don't know the answer for corona
virus herd immunity based on its level of
contagion. We need about 70 percent
immunity in the United States. If three or
four percent of the country gets the virus,
you've got to get immunity and builds natural
immunity, if indeed that's the way it works.
You need about 65, 66 percent of the country
to get vaccinated if only 40 percent plan
to. We have a real problem. I don't have an
answer here in Massachusetts. The flu vaccine
is going to be mandatory this year to attend
public school. A lot of people are furious.
They're saying this is opening the door to
mandatory vaccination. We're going to talk
about that on the bonus show. But you're completely
right. And in fact, Katie, I think you are
understating the problem because it's not
30 percent so far that have said I probably
won't get the vaccine. It's 40 or even 50
percent in the polls that I've seen over the
last couple
of months. Ugly, ugly, ugly stuff. Joined
the discussion on the David Pakman show sub.
Read it at David Pakman dot com slash. Read
it. That's r e d d i t.